with so many new shows premiering it's a
pretty competitive field but these
debuting series have captivated
audiences and critics alike so from
streaming gyms to big Network efforts
here at the very best TV shows of 2019
when critics and audiences heard natasha
Lyonne would be creating her own show
for Netflix they paid attention brush
and all-stars Lyon as Nadia a woman
stuck in a bizarre time loop where she
keeps reliving her death on her birthday
with absolutely no explanation or
context along the way she meets Allen
played by Charlie Barnet who is stuck in
his own terrifying time loop that leads
the two of them to work together to
avoid death solve their seemingly
unsolvable problems hopefully tracked
down Nadia's missing cat oatmeal
the series careful attention to detail
including small recurring motifs like
the ironically cheerful Harry Nielsen
song that plays every time Nadia's
timeline resets earned the show rave
reviews as did Leon's performance in a
role she seems born to play along with
starring she also directed the season
finale and created the concept an
intense involvement that has catapulted
her praise for her work on both sides of
the camera though fans are undoubtedly
excited for a second season season 1
ended on a rare perfect note based on
the famously bizarre comic book series
of the same name Doom Patrol has been
called the best reason to sign up for
the DC Universe streaming service the
highly anticipated series premiered in
early 2019 with a 15 episode first
season focusing on a group of misfits
superheroes trying to save the world
from an eerie supernatural villain known
only as mr. nobody help me out here I'm
inside a donkey or what and the question
is how do we get outside the donkey Doom
Patrol racked up an incredible amount of
praise from critics and comic book fans
alike and for a show that premiered on a
brand new platform based on a relatively
obscure DC property that says an awful
lot about just how good and refreshingly
weird it is led by Saturday Night Live
standout eighty Bryant in her first
starring role who lose shrill is an
adaptation of the book of essays by
Lindy West Bryant doesn't directly play
West who serves as an executive producer
on the show instead taking the role of a
fictional character named Annie who
aspires to become a journalist while
figuring out her messy personal life and
building up her self-esteem throughout
the first season's six episodes annie
stands up to her insensitive boyfriend
attends a life-changing pool party and
make some pretty tough decisions
shrill was hailed as a game changer for
plus-sized women in his portrayal of
Annie as a complex lovable character who
challenges stereotypes typically seen on
television and praised for its
willingness to tackle tough issues with
only six episodes under its belt fans
are dying for more of the series and
they'll get their wish hulu has already
renewed the series for a second season
an adaptation of the poppy
the comic book series by Gerard Way best
known as the frontman for My Chemical
Romance an award-winning artist Gabriel
ba the Umbrella Academy premiered in
February of 2019 the plenty of buzz fans
of the original comic books and viewers
excited about a new superhero series
with a killer cast marathon the 10
episodes series centering on a
mysterious school for children with
supernatural abilities and their lives
as adults in the present day born during
a mysterious event when forty-three
women around the world gave birth in
1989 despite not being pregnant these
children were given numbers rather than
names by the Academy's Headmaster's
original car troops after an ill-fated
career as teen superheroes the
dysfunctional family went their separate
ways
another brought back together for a
funeral they need to work together to
provide the non coming apocalypse
umbrella Academy was a hit for critics
and audiences and the show was renewed
for a second season with the entire cast
and creative team returning for more if
you loved the 2014 comedy what we do in
the shadows then you'll love FX's
television version which premiered in
the spring of 2019 with a new cast and a
new setting the series focuses on three
vampires living as roommates in New York
City Staten Island which they are also
trying to conquer for the entire race of
vampires as you expect Van Pyrrhic
hijinks ensue
ulong's seemed like someone who would be
capable of killing a vampire but I did
it
I liked it maybe a powerful looking guy
believeth the show was created by
Jemaine Clement who oversees it
alongside Tycho ytt the pair co-directed
the original film and the show naturally
shares the charming awkwardness of the
movie it has the same bumbling deadpan
humor that has characterized much of
both Clemente and whitey keys work from
Flight of the Conchords to thor ragnarok
and it's earned rave reviews putting
absurd characters in universal
situations has always been a calling
card for both of these creators and by
giving their vampires new life they've
ended up with another hit on their hands
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite TV shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the belt so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]